بشخصيات الاسبوع التي اشتغلت الصحافه هنا
وهناك في الواقع هنا شخصيتان الاولى هي
الزوجه الامريكيه ميغان ماركل الغائب
الحاضره في ملف الامير هاري والتي تمثل
نقطه تتحول في حياته الملكيه الشخصيه
الثانيه زوجها الامير هاري الذي تحصل
بالولايات المتحده وباعلامها مطلقا قنابله
وعلى عائلته وعلى الاعلام البريطاني بدايه
بلقاء مثير مع الاعلاميه اخرى ثم فيلم
وثائقي على نتفليكس وثلاث لقاءات
تلفزيونيه مع قنوات امريكيه في وقت قياسي
قبل ان يفجر مذكراته وينشرها فالى اي مدى
اثر في الامريكيين واين زوجته خلالها هذه
الضجه اكيد انا الاستطلاعات تظهر ان
الشعبيه الامير تتراجع للمفارقه في امريكا
زاويتنا الامريكيه لقصه الامير مع هند
ابراهيم
الشعور بانك ثانوي قطعه غيار قد تستخدم
عند حدوث كارثه هكذا قضى الامير هاري
حياته سجين احساس بالظلم خلف اسوار القصور
العاليه في لندن حتى حرره الحب وقرر ان
يتحكمه بسرد حكايته في مذكرات حملت عنوان
سبير او الاحتياطي صدرت رسميا اليوم في
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
كشفت المذكرات وتفاصيل محرجه عن الامير
هاري وعائلته الملكيه ولم يسلم منها حتى
الجيش البريطاني ومع تسرب مقاطع من الكتاب
غمرت الانتقادات اللاذعه الاميره وزوجته
ماجن ماركل التي قال انها غير مسؤوله عن
قراره بمواجهه العالم
[موسيقى]
صدوق ودوقه اختار الولايات المتحده ملجا
بعد هروبهما من بلد مثقلين بارثه
الاستعمار والعنصريه المنهجه بحسب هاري
وقالت ماجن في مناسبه عده انها لم تعامل
قبل ذهابها الى لندن كامراه سوداء ما اوحى
بان العنصريه غريبه عن المجتمع الامريكي
وهو اطراء يستدعي رد الجميل ومن اسباب
التعاطف ايضا ان الامريكيين ينظرون الى
هاري وماجن كلثوريين يسعيان الى مناهضه
غياب العداله المؤسساتيه ولزوجين منظمه
غير ربحيه هدفها استثمار التعاطف لاحداث
التغيير في المجتمعات وقد كسب الامير
وزوجته تعاطفا اكبر من خلال الحديث علانيه
عن معاناتهما
[موسيقى]
قصه هاري مع الاعلام الامريكي ليست ورديه
تماما فقد وبخته مقالات نشرت في صحف
امريكيه على تصريحاته الفضائيه عن العائله
الملكيه
وحذرته من مستقبل حافل بندم كثير لكنه لا
يريد بحسب قوله سواء اظهار الحقيقه
لكن الحقيقه اكثر تحديدا مما نعتقد
والاشخاص الاخرين الذين يسكنون قصصنا
لديهم حقائقهم ايضا الامير وليام شقيقه
هاري لديه وجهه نظر قد لا نعرف عنها من
ولي العهد الصامت ابدا يا صباح العربيه
هند ابراهيم واشنطن
ممثله امريكيه والدتها سوداء ووالدها ابيض
هي غائبه عن الصوره لكنها حاضره في قلب
القصه والدها هو توماس دابليو ماركل الحظ
على جائزه ايمي في فئه افضل مدير فني وفتح
لها باب الدخول لعالم الفن حصلت على شهاده
الدراسات المتطوره في المسرح قبل ان تنتهي
من درجه البكالوريوس في المسرح الدولي في
عام 2011 جسده ماركه شخصيه ريتشال زين في
مسلسل سوس حتى انا اشتهرت بهذا الاسم هي
الزوجه السابقه للممثل والمنتج تريفر
انجلسي لكن هو ما انفصل بعد علاقه وزواج
نحو ثمان سنوات
التقت ميغان بهاري في حفل عشاء بحكمه
اهتمامها بالاعمال الخيريه لكن هذه كشف
سابقا في احدى لقاءاته عن فتاه احلامه
وقال انها ميجا ماركل فتاه من اصول
الافريقيه اقتحمت الاسره الملكه كانت هذه
هي كلمات استخدامات صحف بريطانيه في
تقاريرها لوصف عام 2018
ومنذ ارتباطهما وعدسات ووسائل الاعلام حول
العالم تلاحقهما والسبب بحسب هاري في لقاء
الاخير لانها امريكيه وممثله ومطلقه
وسوداء وثنا القات العرق بدات خلافتهما
مبكرا مع التقاليد والعادات الملكيه فكسرت
القواعد باطلالتها البسيطه ببنطال الجنس
والقميص الابيض في ظهورها بعد الزواج
وكذلك العوده لاستخدام وسائل التواصل
[موسيقى]
واشنطن ينضم الينا الصحفي والمتخصص في
الشان الامريكيه ام عباس اهلا بكم ايهاب
معانا في صباح العربيه يعني من المقابلات
الى نتفليكس الى دور النشر هل بالفعل يمكن
القول ان الامير الشاب هاري يستغل الاعلام
الامريكي للشل هجوم شرس ضد عائلته الملكيه
اهلا بحضرتك استاذه سهام واهلا بكل
المشاهدين صباح الخير للجميع لا اعتقد انه
يستغل وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بل وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه هي التي تبحث دائما عن
اخر الاخبار المتعلقه بالامير هاري
وزوجته ميغان كل الامور المتعلقه بهذه
الاسره حتى الان اسره ملكيه طبقا للاعرفه
القليد البريطانيه همم دائما تكون كل
الاخبار المتعلقه بها مسار اما جدل او
استحسان او محاوله للتقرب وتعارف اكثر على
هذه الاسره ومكوناتها خاصه وان هناك
الكثير من اللغط دار حول هذه الاسره
الصغيره منذ ان اجتمعت وتشكلت قبل اعوام
قليله حتى اليوم المواطنين الامريكيين او
المواطنين الامريكيون ينظرون الى ميجا
وهاري على انهما شخصين همم يعني يشكل
الكثير التعاطف والتودد للشعب الامريكي
لذلك هم يتعاطفون مع هاتين الشخصيتين بشكل
كبير خاصه وانهما دائما يظهران انهما لا
يرغبان في الحياه الملكيه وانما يرغبان في
العيش بسعاده وسط المواطنين الامريكيين
ويقدمان الكثير المجتمع الذين يعيشون فيه
بالشكل المطلوب همم بالاضافه طبعا الى ان
التدخلات الصحفيه او عمل قطرات والملاحقات
الصحفيه لهما دائما يجذب التعاطف معهما من
قبل المواطنين الامريكيين بسبب ما يتعرضان
لهما ل همم
كما يصرح عن الاكاذيب والشهاده
اليوم موجود الامير هاري في امريكا
وتصريحات ولكن في المقابل الى اي ماذا
يتحصن ويستفيد الامير هاري من نزعه معاديه
للملكيه في امريكا الجمهوريه
يستفيد كثيرا طبعا خاصه انه يقوم بنشر ما
ينشره دون ردود من
الملكيه البريطانيه حتى اليوم حتى الكتابه
الذي صدر لا تعليق من بريطانيا الاتهامات
التي وجهها لاخيه وليام عبر السنوات
الماضيه بانه كان دائما يحاول ان يجعله او
يشعره بانه رقم اثنين او قطعه غيار كما
ذكر هو على لسان ابيه الملك تشارلز الثالث
عندما اكد انه عندما رزق همم
ويليام ومن ثم هذه قال لزوجته الامير
الاميره الاميره الراحله ديانا همم اليوم
يعني اكملت مهمتك لقد رزقتني بواريف وقطع
غيار ههه منذ ذلك الحين هو الامير هاري
يعتقد انه قطع غيار لذلك جاء كتابه سبير
بنفس المسمى يعني الاحتياطي همم هذا
الشعور لدى همم الامير هاري همم يتنادى
ودائما منذ الصغر وهمم هو الذي قاده لهذه
الفكره اليوم ان يبتعد عن العائله الملكيه
ان يجب ان يبحث لنفسه عن ذات يحققها اا
بعيدا عن
التاج الملكي البريطاني بالرغم بانه يرفض
حتى الان التنازل عن القاب حتى انه سئل في
هذا الاطار قال لما اتنازل عن هذه الالقاب
قيل له لانك لا تريد ان همم تقوم بادوارك
الملكيه وتنازلت عنها فقال لن تحدث اي
فارق الى المتنازل
يحاول ان يحقق ذاته وان يعيش بعيده لكن هو
من يتحرش بالعائله الملكه من خلال هذه
التحصين تصريحات بحسب ما يتردد اليوم الى
اي مدى قد يستفيد الامير هاري من وجوده في
الولايات المتحده ومن هذا التعاطف
الامريكي معه ومع زوجته الغائبه الحاضره
يعني فيما يتعلق بعلاقته مع عائلته و تاج
البريطاني لن يستفيد اي شيء بكل تاكيد
سيخسر كثيرا خلال الفتره القادمه اذا ما
استمر في هذا المنهج ولكن هو في المقابل
ليكسب التعاطف الامريكي لانه يظهر او يظهر
نفسه وزوجته في دور الضحيه لكن هذا
التعاطف لم يستمر الطويلا من وجهه نظري
سيذهب
وقت النسيان في وقت من الاوقات ويكون قصصا
من الماضي لكن بكل تاكيد سيخسر التعاطف من
رعاته الاوليين والاهم وهما انتاج
البريطاني والشعب البريطاني الذي انخفضت
شعبيته شعبيته في اوساطهم بشكل كبير خاصه
مع اعلانه يعني هذا الكتاب قبل ذلك طبعا
الحلقات السته التي اذيعت في نهايه فليكس
والتي ذكر فيها الكثير من المساوئ
والمشكلات التي تعرض لها في المقابل عدم
رد همم الملكيه البريطانيه حتى اليوم عن
اي من ما قاله هاري خلال كتابه او لقاته
التلفزيونيه المختلفه
ايهاب عباس شكرا جزيلا لك